[Music]
in butwhy news submitted by stella be a
banana prank sent a teacher to the
hospital and students to court Oh like
slipping on a banana peel allergic to
the bananas Oh Edie allergic to the
banana that's a really good guys
definitely allergic to the banana that's
a good did someone record themselves
banging their [ __ ] with a banana and
then they sent it to the teacher that's
a better guess okay someone throw a
banana behind them while they were
driving in the teacher ate the banana
[Music]
three seventh grade students at in Ohio
at Starling K through eight school and
Columbus smeared bananas on the doorknob
of a teacher who's deathly allergic to
bananas oh they knew that and they knew
that they not only knew that looked up
but dude there's signs up that says new
atmosphere please that says allergic to
bananas if you had one today please wash
your hands and these little shits then
that's a salt there's the weapon like
deadly banana like if you know someone
is deathly allergic
isn't that attempted murder full of
potassium
yeah dude so the kids knew it and that's
they all knew that if it touches her she
goes into anaphylactic shock and they
still thought it would be funny they
wanted to see it why they were curious I
mean this happened to my niece like
she's [ __ ] deadly allergic to peanuts
and his kid [ __ ] chased her with a
peanut butter jelly sandwich laugh
really hard because it seems so silly
him running around with a peanut butter
jelly sandwich and she's [ __ ] running
for her life yeah and I'm like yeah and
then I'm yeah and I'm a [ __ ] up uncle
but you know what she walks home with
like a EpiPen
just yeah yeah yeah so she does home
schooling now cuz she's like [ __ ] dude
like they don't know how serious this is
yeah [ __ ] those [ __ ] kids man I had a
friend in elementary school that
a chick threw like peanuts enemies like
deathly allergic and then she like got
this big ol like almost almost
suspension like they didn't suspend her
but they like really close to cuz like
she was he was like I'm deathly allergic
peony like no no I start throwing it I
was like that's uh can you just get if
you're allergic to peanuts and throw it
at you and the shell hits you does that
yeah if he touches you yeah I was hit
with a peanut actually right in my eye
what's a baseball game and this guy was
trying to throw it to his wife to get
her attention and it just be me right
now I and you're allergic no I'm sorry
that would scare me
so yeah the teacher of course touched
the doorknob after the kids smeared it
all over the doorknob she touches it she
goes immediately in it and if I could
just from touching it ah she starts to
change colors yeah they they throw on
the ground they shoot an EpiPen into her
chest and it didn't work
oh [ __ ] if she died and her throat
started to calls oh no and then they
gave her another one and then it started
to be better for her holy SH she did not
know the kids were watching all of this
were they like this honey laughing I
think that it became real for that but
they didn't say but I would hope that it
became real for public teritama ties is
such a funny allergies you just didn't
believe it there's right you look at a
banana and go oh my god oh but that but
that is a funny fruit though it's
hilarious really it's kind of sexy and
funny it's sexy and funny it got all the
proper things that you need you can [ __ ]
the peel if you're of a certain age you
put it in the microwave and you can [ __ ]
the Pete really hey what are you talking
to him you did that [ __ ] the peel I
may have done that like I can neither
confirm nor deny it so it's a vagina put
it in the microwave and soften it up a
little bit okay so both genders can use
it damn I wish I knew that one if your
mom comes in your room she doesn't go
like oh [ __ ] man she's like oh we
hate a banana she sees the peel in the
garbage and [ __ ] oh okay there's no like
tissues with residue and [ __ ] you just
[ __ ] the banana and she doesn't know you
were the guy though you're the guy that
watched American Pie you're like my man
honestly I wasn't allowed to watch
American Pie
yeah so I didn't even know I'd feel
something with suspect if there was come
on a banana
you're not like looking through the
[ __ ] yeah I don't know plus your have
a devious kid oh yes it has a banana
you're not gonna be like oh what the
[ __ ] this is [ __ ]
kids bananas even so many bananas like
has ever fill up a plastic bag with
water and then try to [ __ ] oh no no
no no but I knew a kid in high school
that [ __ ] drilled a hole in the
cantaloupe and [ __ ] it there he goes
this thing became cantaloupe weight he
told all of his friends in the economy
whether brother caught him until
everyone can us as a solid as fruit so
they all got charged with the salt yeah
and the juvenile court system serve
probation and they were transferred to
other schools
oh damn for attempted murder the patient
right now you know what but the kids
though like if you're probably would
have done stupid [ __ ] like that in
seventh grade it's hard to punish kids
in the same way it's so hard to tell a
kid don't do this
yeah cuz then they want to do it so bad
including me I do in the same way yeah
would you would you have gone that far
though to like [ __ ] someone that had
an allergy that like stuff like that
I've been told like for my kid kid it'd
be like he's really allergic do not do
and I feel like oh [ __ ] that sounds kind
of scary well when I was in eighth grade
I had a friend we went to Dairy Queen
and he's allergic to peanuts not deadly
allergic and I was like you but you have
to try this blizzard with the Reese's
peanut butter things in it
and I was pretty adamant for like a good
hour to and tell me like yes and he goes
I'm [ __ ] allergic and then I'm like I
just thought he got butthurt so I
respected that he got butthurt I
believed that he was really you don't
know how good this Terra
and I wasn't choosing him around right
right you know to understand how stupid
a kid can be ready you're the most
annoying kid I've ever heard about you
pester kid for an hour like try mine
milkshake my buddy so I want him to
enjoy the same joys that I have I'd say
the worst thing I did was try to get
this kid to believe that he had a lisp I
was I was like say Thursday
he's like Thursday I'm like you did see
you did all right there and I spent like
the whole day I listen bro listen every
time you say I swear juice you spit try
Saturday Saturday I'm like and they're
like Wes stop relax let him go legal if
I was just really pressed I was like I
don't really feel is he had the worst
list or he had you say Thursday not
Thursday
I thought you convinced the guy I was
just like really trying to teach him how
to talk without wind well it came from a
good place a good place yeah
execution was me yeah yeah just taking a
little bit too persistent you ever tried
to get a guy that stutters to stop when
I went to I had an internship with
Disney World
there my roommate he he had I was the
other tick called Tourette's Tourette
yeah he just blurts out [ __ ]
yeah you blurt out [ __ ] but using verbal
brainstorm we could we could do without
missing a beat was spit out Ice Ice Baby
thank you
oh no he would get that she listen every
time like and I mean every time every
time like it would come on it'd be his
moment to just not stutter not take I
was nothing that was his thing what was
his normal tic so what do you normally
say he he'd kind of like do a jaw thing
where he like stretch it and then any
bad words yeah all times all the time
what was the main one oh it's tough we
can't say anymore oh really
is it a six letter F word nah he'd just
be like you like yeah and the tissues
are at [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and then just get
bright back into the conversation and
you guys are talking about flowers or
something normal
yeah we're talking around a seven normal
but I give it so I came in a [ __ ]
cheeto bag always bad word there's
nothing like bubble beads or rainbows
and stuff you know like at first it was
like funny but then I got used to no
like I was [ __ ] like this is he doesn't
want to do it yeah just yeah [ __ ] her
it's crazy cuz it's like the worst [ __ ]
you can say yeah it's never like [ __ ]
Donuts and sprinkles look I wish it was
that right yeah yeah what it's like [ __ ]
man
I'd be happy for him when you know I
stuck him on but it did start get
annoying yeah is he how long were the
last huh how much of the song would you
say the song cuz now that was where he
had clear thoughts and he would be able
to do one thing without Tourette's n'
men yeah he would kill that song I met a
guy with Tourette's I was working on the
real Ian Johnson so many years ago and
this guy came through and he's a
stand-up comedian who has Tourette's Wow
how do you like working straight sit
into a safe that's pretty cool name's
Sam Conroy stuff that's really cool I
was hoping you wouldn't get offended if
you laugh at him because he's having
Tourette's and he he wasn't he was
joking about it like you can he got he
beat you to the punch like he was always
yeah if you're stand-up comedian then
you have Tourette's you have to let you
have to like figure out a way to like
work that ain't mad about that today
because everybody's [ __ ] offended and
I'm like comics are like supposed to be
the least offended that's just the thing
that they're supposed to do but it's
like the opposite now some comics are
offended yeah which is crazy yeah yeah
it's crazy at any time I don't know I
don't know if it's our generation are
the people that are older than us but
someone's offended all the time yeah and
then when I look at the type of people
that are offended though it's all ages
it's not it's just the time man it's not
a certain group it's like I see old
folks I see very younger like there was
some like
and Stimpy they'd have some like really
like crazy ass [ __ ] and then we get
older and then it's like that offended
me so like is it us but have you noticed
that some people think that we're
getting triggered because they're
offended yeah cuz we're reacting to
their being offended and they're like
you guys are getting triggered and I'm
like that's more than if they understand
what you're saying but record because
I'm triggered and you're you're offended
of my offensive that offended mr. new
[ __ ] jujitsu vid yeah yeah that's next
level of thinking though that's kind of
like wait I am annoyed I am annoyed that
you're offended oh no it's like damn who
started it
I've seen that said like Oh
steveandgeorge so triggered right now
I'm like here like we watching it there
I get I get triggered by the fact that
they call out the triggered when I
wasn't even triggered right and it's
like I wasn't even mad I was just
breathing and that's in there my
computer like oh no am I getting woke
because I realize that I'm being tricky
like turn around you slap me Nicki
figure my butt real head I guess I like
that now